>> Laura: WATCHING ANATURAL SIS
OF THE STONE ARREST, MAN, I
JUST -- ANALYSIS, I JUST SAW A
SHOCKING LACK OF HONEST AND
OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS.
EVEN FORMER DNI, JIM CLAPPER,
WAS MAKING HUGE LEAPS WITH RANK
SPECULATION.
>> BASED ON THESE SERIES OF
COMMUNICATIONS THAT STONE WAS
HAVING WITH SENIOR TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS, OFTEN IN
ADVANCE OF WIKILEAKS RELEASES,
E-MAILS STOLEN BY RUSSIA, WHAT
DOES THAT SHOW TO YOU, IS THAT
EVIDENCE IN YOUR VIEW, OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA?
>> WELL, IT DOES TO ME, I SAY
THAT, NOT AS AN ATTORNEY BUT
JUST AS A LAYMAN.
I THINK CLEARLY, IT DOES SHOW
CONNECTION, COORDINATION,
SYNCHRONIZATION, WHATEVER YOU
CALL IT.
>> Laura: OKAY, NICE TRY.
NOTHING OF THE SORT WAS
INDICATED IN THE INDICTMENT.
I MEAN, THIS IS WHERE PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT GO ON TV IF THEY
DON'T BOTHER TO READ THE
INDICTMENT.
BASELESS FROM FORMER DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
WE MIGHT REREMIND YOU COMMITTED
OPEN PERJURY DURING THE OBAMA
YEARS AND FACED ZERO PENALTIES.
WHERE IS THE JUSTICE.
TONIGHT WE'LL EXPOSE MEN LIKE
THAT AND ELD KATE YOU, THE
VIEWER, ALONG THE WAY.
WE PUT TOGETHER AN UNBELIEVABLE
PANEL.
THE POLITICAL AND LEGAL ASPECTS
AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ASPECTS
REGARDING THAT ELIAN GONZALEZ
STYLE RAID ON STONE'S HOUSE.
PHIL WISEN BERG, FORMER DECK
DIRECTOR OF WHITEWATER, BYRON
YORK FOR THE POLITICAL ANALYSIS,
FROM THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER,
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
SOME ONE WHO'S DONE MORE
REPORTING THAN MOST PEOPLE ON
THE FAFGTS PLAN OAT THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, SAUL.
NOW, YOU READ THE INDICTMENT,
TONIGHT, WHAT YOU JUST HEARD
FROM ONE OF ROGER STONE'S
LAWYERS TELLS YOU WHAT?
>> WELL, HE'S ACTING LIKE ANY
GOOD DEFENSE LAWYER WOULD ACT.
I LOOK AT THE INDICTMENT AND
OBVIOUSLY, IF HE REALLY DID, THE
STRONGEST PARTS OF THE
INDICTMENT ARE THE ALLEGATIONS
OF LYING DIRECTLY TO CONGRESS.
THE WEAKEST PART HAS TO DO WITH
THE SO-CALLED INTIMIDATION OF
ONE OF THE OTHERS WHO WAS
TESTIFYING.
I LOOK AT THE INDICTMENT, ALL OF
THESE INDICTMENTS THAT ARE FOR
LYING, IT'S NOT THAT LYING ISN'T
A SERIOUS CRIME, LIKE YOU SAY,
BUT IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF
THINGS P YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHAT
IS REALLY BEING SUPPOSEDLY
ULTIMATELY INVESTIGATED,
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY, THERE'S A
TERM OF ART IN CRIMINAL DEFENSE
WORLD FOR THESE KINDS OF
CHARGES.
IT'S TWO WORDS, THE FIRST WORD
IS CHICKEN AND THE LAST WORD
ENDS IN "IT."
THAT'S WHAT MOST OF THESE
CHARGES ARE LIKE.
FOR THE PEOPLE, LOOK, IT'S NOT A
GESTAPO RAID, NOT AN ELIAN GONLZ
RAID.
>> Laura: ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> IT WAS AN APPROPRIATE SEARCH.
I HEARD ROGER STONE SAY ONCE
THEY CAME IN, AND ARRESTED HIM,
THEY WERE VERY COURTEOUS.
DON'T GET ME WRONG, LET'S NOT
COMPARE TO IT THE NAZIS.
INAPPROPRIATE SEARCH, AND THE
PEOPLE SAYING IT WAS APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE THEY HAD A SEARCH
WARRANT AND HE WAS GOING TOO
DESTROY EVIDENCE, THEY COULD
HAVE SEARCHED HIM BEFORE THE
INDICTMENT.
>> Laura: RIGHT, THAT'S THE
POINT I WAS MAKING.
>> LIKE THEY DID WITH MANAFORT.
POINT NUMBER TWO, HE WAS
RELEASED ON $250,000 PERSONAL
RECOGNIZANCE.
I DON'T THINK THE MUELLER PEOPLE
CHALLENGED THAT.
SO HE'S NO FLIGHT RISK AT ALL.
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
INDICTMENT THAT SAYS THAT HE WAS
DESTROYING EVIDENCE.
>> Laura: OKAY.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS SOME OF THESE
COMMENTS.
>> Laura: I MEAN, SEMANTICS
ASIDE, JOE, I WANT YOUR REACTION
TO THIS.
THIS IS FORMER CIA DIRECTOR,
YOUR FAVORITE PERSON, JOE, I
CAN'T BELIEVE YOU AREN'T HAVING
DRINKS TONIGHT, JOHN BRENNAN,
MAKING PREDICTIONS FOR THE NEXT
TWO MONTHS.
>> THERE WAS AN EXTENSIVE EFFORT
TO TRY TO INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME.
ELECTION, THAT INVOLVED THE
RUSSIANS, THAT INVOLVED U.S.
PERSONS, AND THAT MAY HAVE GONE
TO THE VERY TOP OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
I EXPECT THAT WITHIN THE NEXT 60
DAYS YOU WILL HAVE A FAIR NUMBER
OF INDICTMENTS.
>> FAIR?
>> FAIR NUMBER, SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF INDICTMENTS.
>> Laura: JOE, HE CAN READ
MINDS, TOO.
>> WELL, JOHN BRENNAN WAS PART
OF A CONSPIRACY TO FRAME DONALD
TRUMP.
HE WENT TO LONDON, MET WITH THE
NSA OF THE UK, ARRANGED FOR
FALSE INTELLIGENCE TO BE FED
INTO THE UNITED STATES TOWNS
ASSIST IN ACQUIRING FALSE FISA
WARRANTS.
WHAT JOHN BRENNAN HAS TO SAY
REALLY DOESN'T MATTER.
LAURA, BEFORE WE MOVE AWAY FROM
IT, I WANT TO SAY THAT THE RID
THIS MORNING -- THE RAID THIS
MORNING, TO ARREST ROGER STONE,
WAS ONE OF THE MOST VINDICTIVE,
UNPROFESSIONAL ACTIONS EVER
CONDUCTED BY THE U.S. DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
BOB MUELLER, ALL OF HIS MINIONS,
CHRIS RAY, ROD ROSENSTEIN, AND
THE ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL MATT
WHITAKER SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY UNNECESSARY.
IT WAS DONE FOR VINDICTIVE
REASONS.
IT IS THE BEGINNING OF THE FINAL
DEGRADATION OF THE FBI AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND THE FACT THAT CHRIS RAY AND
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND WHITAKER
ALLOWED THIS TO OCCUR, BECAUSE
THEY WERE AWARE OF IT, THEY DID
NOT STOP IT, THEY KNEW IT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN, IT IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, AND IT REALLY,
REALLY MAKES IT IMPORTANT THAT A
VERY SERIOUS PERSON TAKE OVER
THE DEPARTMENT, BILL BARR, SO
THAT PEOPLE LIKE CHRIS RAY CAN
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Laura: 29 AGENTS.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY BAKED
COOKIES FOR STONE.
>> IT IS AN EMBARRASSMENT.
>> Laura: IF THEY BREWED COFFEE
FOR STONE ONCE THEY GOT IN
THERE, IT WAS SHOW FOR CNN.
IT WAS TOTAL SHOW.
>>ED A LESS YENT BEHAVIOR.
>> Laura: 15 OUTPOSTS THEY
NEEDED TO COVER?
BYRON, NO, YOU WROTE A -- BYRON
YORK, YOU SAY IT'S NOT WHAT IS
IN THE INDICTMENT, THEY COULD
HAVE WRITTEN THAT IN THREE
PAGES, IT'S WHAT IS NOT IN THE
INDICTMENT.
EXPLAIN THAT, PLEASE.
>> WHAT'S NOT IN THE INDICTMENT
IS AN ALLEGATION THAT THERE WAS
A CONSPIRACY, BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA TO FIX THE
2016 ELECTION.
THAT'S JUST NOT THERE.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S REALLY
NOT THERE, IS EVIDENCE OF ANY
KNOWLEDGE BEFORE HAND, OF ROGER
STONE, ABOUT WHAT WIKILEAKS WAS
GOING TO DO.
THE MOST LOOKED-AT PARAGRAPH IN
THE WHOLE THING, THE PARAGRAPH,
ON JULY 22nd, 2016, WHEN THE
WIKILEAKS DISCLOSURES HAPPENED,
THEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN GOT IN
TOUCH WITH ROGER STONE, SAID
WHAT'S GOING ON.
THIS WAS AFTER THE FACT.
>> Laura: BUT I HAVE A
QUESTION --
>> ONE MORE THING.
SUGGESTS THERE WAS NOT A
COLLUSION SCHEME IN PLACE.
AND RUNNING WHEN IT HAPPENED.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GO TO SAUL.
WHEN I HEAR BYRON DESCRIBE, THIS
I THINK TO MYSELF, BIG DEAL.
LIKE ROGER STONE WANTED TO FIND
OF THE, WHEN WAS THE NEXT ONE
COMING.
THEY WERE PAYING FOR
RUSSIAN-SOURCED FALSE, PHONY,
SALACIOUS INFORMATION ON DONALD
TRUMP THAT WAS SOURCED IN
RUSSIA.
THEY WERE PAYING A U.S. FIRM TO
HELP DISSEMINATE IT, INCLUDING
UP TO JOHN McCAIN'S OFFICE AND
EVERYONE ELSE WHO HAD IT.
SOMEHOW THIS GUY, ROGER STONE,
ENDS UP ARRESTED TODAY, PREDAWN?
REALLY?
I MEAN, TO ME, IT'S CRAZY.
>> LAWYER, A I'M SURPRISED AT
YOU, LAURA.
I'M SURPRISED AT YOU.
I DON'T SEE WHY YOU'RE NOT MORE
EXCITED ABOUT PARAGRAPH 12 OF
THE INDICTMENT.
I LOOK ON MSNBC, AND CNN,
THEY'RE ORGASMIC OVER IT.
>> Laura: THAT'S THE FIRST TIME
THAT WORD HAS BEEN USED ON OUR
SHOW.
AND IT IS FRIDAY NIGHT.
>> THIS IS THE PARAGRAPH THAT
EVERYBODY IS SO EXCITED ABOUT.
BECAUSE IT TALKS ABOUT STONE
BEING DIRECTED OR ASKED BY
SENIOR MEMBER OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TO FIND OUT WHEN THE
NEXT RELEASE IS GOING TO BE.
LOOK, IT CERTAINLY, IF TRUE, IS
EMBARRASSING TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, PERHAPS.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK SO.
WHO CARES?
>> BUT, BUT, BUT, THINK ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING, THEY'RE
SAYING THAT SOMEBODY IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, IF TRUE, LEARNED
ABOUT THIS, THERE WAS PLENTY OF
REPORTING ABOUT THIS, AND THEY
ASKED STONE TO FIND OUT WHEN THE
NEXT RELEASE IS GOING TO BE.
I'M SORRY, BUT THAT ALONE IS NOT
ANY KIND OF A CRIME.
AND IT CERTAINLY IS NOT
CONSPIRACY TO HACK THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM OR HACK SOMEBODY'S
COMPUTER, OR TO ACCEPT BENEFITS
FROM THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
IT JUST ISN'T.
BUT IT'S THE UM TEENLTH
INDICTMENT IN THE CASE WHERE
PEOPLE COME ON LIKE BRENNAN AND
CLAPPER, AND SAY YOU WILL SEE A
BUNCH OF INDICTMENTS IN THE NEXT
TWO WEEKS, AND IT'S PART OF
MUELLER'S MASTER PLAN TO DRIBBLE
OUT, IT'S ALL PAMPBT OF THE
MASTER PLAN TO DRIBBLE OUT THE
INDICTMENTS, DRIBBLE OUT THE
INFORMATION.
IT IS JUST, SO FAR, NOT THERE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY FOR
YOU --
>> LAURA?
>> Laura: GO AHEAD, JOE.
>> LAURA, VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
PUTTING ON TOP OF WHAT SAUL JUST
SAID.
EVERY BIT OF BEHAVIOR OF ROGER
STONE AND THE OTHER PEOPLE NAMED
IN THE INDICTMENT, AND THE TRUMP
PEOPLE, WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
THE ALLEGATIONS OF STONE FOR
LYING OBSTRUCTION, ALL OF THE
OTHER BEHAVIOR IS PERFECTLY
LEGAL.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THE TRUMP
PEOPLE WANTED TO KNOW WHEN THE
NEXT ONE WAS GOING TO HIT.
>> Laura: WHY IS THAT A CRIME?
>> THAT IS A LEGAL QUESTION.
THAT IS A LEGAL QUESTION.
YOU CAN DO THAT, IT'S CALLED
POLITICAL INTELLIGENCE.
>> Laura: IT'S OPPO RESEARCH.
THE CLINTONS DID THAT.
>> NOTHING IN THE INDICTMENT
ABOUT ANY OF THE PEOPLE INVOLVED
IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN OR ROGER
STONE OR PERSON NUMBER ONE OR
PERSON NUMBER TWO IS ILLEGAL
EXCEPT THE LYING.
I THINK THEY'RE DONE WITH ME.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING, BYRON, RICK TYLER
TODAY ON MSNBC.
IT'S IMPORTANT, PEEP AIM CROSS
THE COUNTRY, IN THE KITCHEN,
MAKING DINNER FOR THEIR KIDS,
OH, MY GOD, THIS IS TERRIBLE.
I DEALT WITH THIS AS A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE LAWYER, READING THESE
INDICTMENTS, THE PEOPLE ARE
FREAKING OUT ABOUT IT.
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE PUT IN
CONTEXT.
THEN YOU HAVE THE LEAP FROM
NEVER-TRUMPERS, LIKE RICK.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A POLITICAL
CON MAN WHOSE SHOWMANSHIP HAS
CAUGHT UP TO HIM.
IT SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED THAT
ROGER STONE HAS BEEN INDICTED
FOR PERJURY.
HE'S A PRACTITIONER IN THE
POLITICAL DARK ARTS, KNOWN FOR
DIRTY TRICKS, AND I THINK A
LIFETIME OF THIS SHTICK HAS
FINALLY CAUGHT UP WITH HIM.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY SHTICK IS
THE FEDERAL CRIME.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
THAT'S ANALYSIS ON TELEVISION
TODAY.
>> STONE DID MAKE PROBLEMS FOR
HIMSELF IN THIS WAY, HE BRAGGED
ABOUT ALL SORTS OF THINGS,
SUGGESTED HE HAD BEEN IN TOUCH
WITH JULIAN ASSANGE WHEN HE
HADN'T, BUT HE SAID IT PUBLICLY.
AFTER SAYING THAT PUBLICLY, HE
GOES IN FRONT OF THE HOUSE AND
THEY ASK HIM ABOUT HIS PUBLIC
STATEMENTS.
EXCEPT THIS TIME HE'S UNDER
OATH.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T TILL THE TRUTH
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING, HE IS
CERTAINLY ACCUSED OF LYING ABOUT
IT.
I WAS HIS OWN BRAGGING THAT GOT
HIM INTO TROUBLE.
>> Laura: NEVER BRAG.
>> GOOD IDEA.
>> Laura: VERY QUICKLY, SAUL,
WILL THERE BE ANOTHER BIG
HIGH-PROFILE INDICTMENT COMING
OUT OF MUELLER'S OFFICE OR AS
DAVID FRENCH SAID, THIS A SIGN
IT HAS TO WRAP UP?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA BUT THERE'S
SOMETHING NO ONE IS TALKING
ABOUT, WHAT A DEMOCRATIC TOWN
AND TRUMP-HATING TOWN D.C. IS,
AND THAT'S WHERE ROGER STONE IS
GOING TO BE TRIED IN FRONT OF A
JURY OF HIS ALLEGED PEERS.
AND WE SHOULD NEVER FORGET THAT.
IT'S A BAD TOWN FOR REPUBLICAN
DEFENDANTS.
>> Laura: EXCELLENT POINT, JOE
KNOWS THAT.
>> ASK SCOOTER LIBBY.
>> Laura: BINGO, HAD TO GET